let's get more now on the government's
new immigration policy announced earlier
today the prime minister revealed
details of this controversial new plan
to fly asylum seekers to rwanda for
processing in a bid to tackle migrant
crossings in the channel boyce johnson
and pretty patel say that this deal will
stop people smugglers exploiting
vulnerable people and turning the
channel into a graveyard however
charities have today slammed the move
describing it as a cruel and nasty
decision that will fail and only lead to
more human suffering um well to give us
the perspective from rwanda uh joining
us from the capital yolanda makolo
spokesperson for the rwandan government
uh ms mccolow good to see you this
afternoon thank you for joining us
thank you for having me um why has
rwanda built this partnership with the
uk to take in asylum seekers what's the
benefit to rwanda
oh run has a strong record of receiving
uh migrants and refugees for the last 28
years we've hosted more than 130 000
refugees from neighboring countries
we've also uh more recently uh welcomed
refugees from you know from evacuated
from dangerous situations in in libya um
and and other refugees including uh
afghanis who live with us in our
community so we have this long
experience
in welcoming and hosting refugees here
we also have the experience of being
refugees or displaced because of our
recent history of conflict so we know
what it means to be desperate for for a
safe haven and for opportunities to live
a decent and dignified life
from your understanding those that have
flown from the uk to rwanda
are they on a one-way ticket because we
heard the prime minister say that they
will be processed in your country and
that they should be encouraged to build
a life there is that your understanding
if they are proven to be genuine asylum
seekers
they will not be allowed to return to
the uk
yeah so
this migration and economic development
partnership that we just agreed and
signed with the uk today
is a new innovative model where we uh we
will offer safety and protection to to
migrants who will be able to make a
asylum claim here
and offered protection even even though
even if the asylum claims are do not go
through they will be allowed to stay
here and make a life here and will be
offered legal pathways to residency and
opportunities to to develop themselves
alongside rondons
um but people have a legal right to seek
asylum in whatever country they want and
if they've landed on the shores of the
uk international law says they have the
right to seek asylum in the uk if they
are flown to rwanda processed and found
to be
genuine asylum seekers will they be
allowed to return to the uk
iraq is a signatory to the refugee
convention and we have an asylum process
of our own people are entitled to safety
and they're entitled to seek
to to seek asylum uh but they do not
have an infected choice of the country
that they um that they that they go to
so we are offering uh safety and
protection here and an opportunity to
build a decent and dignified life
but international law says that people
have the right to seek asylum in
whatever country they want that's where
the confusion is because we're talking
about people who are coming to the uk to
seek asylum then they're heading well
they're being taken to rwanda to be
processed what i'm trying to understand
is
you know what's the legal basis for
what's happening here
uh there is a legal basis for for this
partnership but there are no
international we're not breaking any or
violating any conventions uh people do
have a right to seek safety and asylum
uh what international international law
does not say that they have a
choice of country to go to the country
though that he's expecting court
challenges so this is legally
complicated it's not as cut and dry as
you land in the uk and you head to
rwanda and that's where you have to seek
asylum it's not that cut and dry
um it may be not we're clear on what we
want with this uh with this from this
partnership we want to provide a
solution to a global problem working
with the uk we want to to to offer
safety to to migrants and not only
asylum seekers a lot of
asylum seekers are not actually refugees
but it doesn't matter everyone has a
right to live a decent life and we
believe in rwanda that
africans and other people from elsewhere
um should be able to live a safe and
dignified life uh here and be offered
the opportunity to thrive um yeah let's
talk about that opportunity you say
you're offering of a safe and dignified
life because a lot of charities have
called this move to to take asylum
seekers to rwanda wrong they're pointing
at your country's human rights record
saying rwanda does not have a human a
good human rights record human rights
watch says um you know several
high-profile critics have been arrested
or threatened in 2015 relatively
recently um a uk judge refused to
extradite five men to rwanda because she
argued it's an authoritarian repressive
state stifling opposition and is
suspected of threatening and killing
opponents people have been tortured in
secret camps can you address those
concerns
well no one is more interested in human
rights than rwanda uh for the last 28
years we have uh built a country that is
united a country that is stable and that
uh has uh run where what london's uh
believe and trust in the government we
have built a functioning government that
provides uh services for rwandans and
they trust uh our government programs
for instance with the with covet 19
we've been able to manage uh the
pandemic quite well in rwanda because
people trust the government human rights
watch might say whatever they say but
that's up to them it doesn't mean that
it's the truth we are interested in
rights for rwandans um in all rights the
right to live a dignified life the right
to for help for education we want this
for all londons we want this for
migrants who come and live with us
um elaine just one final question to you
thank you so much for taking the time
today but just one final question if i
may uh your foreign minister uh has been
speaking and was talking about this
partnership with the uk and said that
rwanda however would not be welcoming
migrant migrants from neighbouring
countries
i wonder if you have any caveats about
who you will and who you won't accept
because
a lot of those migrants coming to the uk
are from places like syria and
afghanistan but they're also from places
like iran and eritrea eritrea a country
closer to you than the uk
will you accept
migrants from all countries or do you
have exceptions
we don't have exceptions migrants are
people
and what we want to do is invest in
people so there will be no
the only exceptions are
because we do have the option to to
reject uh transfer
of people from the uk
uh for instance in cases uh that concern
our national security we will have that
option if uh for instance uh from
information provided by the uk
government that this individual has a
criminal background
then we would
exercise our right to refuse
that individual but it's on a
case-by-case basis but we will accept
migrants from everywhere